lo primero que tienes que saber es que
no será nada fácil vas a extrañar a tu
familia vas a querer ver deportes con tu
papá vas a necesitar la bendición de tu
mamá vas a anhelar abrazar a tus
hermanas
vas a cortar con tu novia y vas a
valorar todo lo que tenías en casa ya no
te van a atender la cama no te van a
lavar la ropa y no te van a preparar de
comer
vas a llorar muchísimo el día que te
vayas empezará así abrazar a tu familia
una y otra vez y no será suficiente
será un nudo en la garganta llegará a la
hora de partir y te irás
empezarás a caminar por el aeropuerto de
tijuana y aunque tengas más miedos que
ganas comenzarás a sentir paz y entonces
te preguntarás porque me estoy sintiendo
bien y la respuesta será porque vas en
el camino correcto
tenías que irte a casa tenías que salir
de tu zona de confort porque mientras
más grande sea el sacrificio mayor será
la recompensa pero no te va a ir bien al
principio y volverán las dudas
tendrás miedo dudarán de ti y te harán
dudar de ti vas a batallar mucho te vas
a quedar solo te va a hacer falta dinero
pero nunca pasará hambre
te quedarás dormido en tu primer día de
clases y no tendrás tiempo ni de bañarte
reprobará algunas materias pero las
calificaciones no son lo más importante
serás campeón nacional sin embargo no
serás titular y eventualmente dejaras el
fútbol americano mucho antes de lo
planeado
y entonces mexicalli se convertirá en tu
lugar favorito para ir de vacaciones
valorará su ciudad como nunca antes y
regresarás y cuando estés aquí serás el
más feliz y le pedirás la bendición a
toda tu familia y les darás más besos y
más abrazos y nunca serán suficientes
pero te juro
te juro que tú vas a estar ahí
volverás a irte volverás a llorar y
porque así es la vida querrá regresar y
algún día regresará si todo habrá valido
la pena porque cumplirás todos tus
sueños de niño
debutará en televisión nacional te
volverás conocido en monterrey y hasta
perderás el piso irás a tu primer super
bowl y green bay será campeón cubrir as
unos juegos olímpicos y méxico ganará la
medalla de oro de fútbol
seguirás a la selección mexicana y le
ganarán alemania en tu primer mundial
y tú vas a estar ahí
sólo se paciente
se bueno tomará tiempo habrá obscuridad
te van a reventar de volverás viral
hablarán de ti se reducirá tu círculo
quitarás más fuerte y entonces volverá a
empezar
por eso nunca pierdas la fe
jamás dejes de creer
confía en ti pero confía más en dios
sé tú
todos los demás y existen
y recuerda que si algo no está bien
es porque todavía no es el final
carta a mí mismo
cuando gracias
cuándo
y me invitaron a hacer xx mexicalli
sentí un orgullo brutal de pensar que un
día yo estar acá donde estuve en una
pastorela en 3º de secundaria
dónde
me entregaron el premio al mejor jugador
defensivo del año en el 2005
y sobre todo donde me gradué de la prepa
en un mes exactamente en un mes el 22 de
julio del 2006
en un mes se cumplen 13 años desde que
me fui a mexicalli y como verán sigo
extrañando nuestra ciudad
pero en estos 13 años
he aprendido algunas cosas que quería
compartir con ustedes
mientras más grande sea el sacrificio
mayor será la recompensa y es que cuando
sales de tu zona de confort entras en
una misión no encuentro está manera de
ponerlo en palabras pero
dónde está mi familia para ubicarlos
venga
nada ha sido tan difícil como irme a
casa nada ni cerca nada nada se le
compara y entonces cuando pasa algo en
el canal en el trabajo en la vida
solo pienso en si me pude ir de mi casa
si puedo dejar a mis papás y mis
hermanas mis tíos mis primos a mis
abuelos todo estará bien
ni modo que no pueda
pude irme de mi casa y entras en esa
misión y de pronto en esa misión tienes
que hacer que valga la pena no estar con
tu familia
porque ya te fuiste ya no hay besos ya
no hay abrazos ya no hay bendición ya no
hay comida ya no hay ropa lavada y
entonces tienes que hacer que valga la
pena no estar con tu familia todo el día
todos los días
se dice bien fácil pero los cumpleaños
las grabaciones y las fiestas y los 10
de mayo si el día del padre por una
parte y por otra el día a día
las comidas la cena la plática el café
y entras en una misión y entonces se
trata de hacer que valga la pena no
estar con ellos mientras más grande sea
el sacrificio mayor será la recompensa
ni el 10 de calificación
te asegura el éxito ni el 5 te condena
al fracaso
nunca nadie me ha preguntado ni con qué
promedio me gradué del cetys mexicali
ni con que promedió me gradué del tec de
monterrey y ni me pregunten
porque yo les voy a contar mis papás no
están muy orgullosos pero lo siento hay
que ser bien transparentes hay que ser
muy honestos y hay que aprovechar estar
aquí parado
me gradué con
8.01 del promedio de la prepa
por si fuera poco me gradué con 7.9
promedio de la universidad
y saben que no pasan nada
no pasa nada nunca me han preguntado
nunca en una entrevista de trabajo
uy qué calificación sacaste en la
carrera con cuánto promedio te grabó
hasta en la prepa por favor es
indispensable saber para contratarte 7.9
de promedio
con eso no quiero que los burros se
emocionen y digan si el diputado
más bien lo que quiero es que
los que son muy aplicados los que son
muy dedicados los sigan siendo pero que
sepan que eso no lo es todo el mejor
promedio de la generación el 9.8 9.9 el
10 de calificación no les asegura el
éxito hay muchas cosas
qué forman los componentes para ser
exitoso muchas otras más que las
calificaciones las calificaciones son
muy importantes pero no son lo más
importante
entonces pónganse a estudiar
y pónganse a trabajar
los burros a estudiar ya drogas
a la gente buena le va bien no hay duda
no hay duda de verdad lo peor que puede
pasar cuando seas bueno buena gente buen
ser humano buena persona
lo peor que puede pasar es que vivas en
paz
luz peor
y la paz está
muy poco valorada en este mundo
necesitamos más gente que esté en paz
y si eres bueno si haces las cosas bien
si haces lo que te toca hacer cuando te
toca hacer cómo te toca hacerlo
vas a estar bien y vas a estar en paz
de nada sirve tenerlo todo si no tienes
con quien compartirlo de nada no se
trata del dinero no se trata hasta que
empiezas a ganar y te depositan y lo
tienes y lo ves en la aplicación del
banco más metes la tarjeta al cajero la
paz así se huella tengo dinero
está bien que bueno y te van a depositar
un mes y te vas a emocionar muchísimo y
la quincena y otra vez otro mes y te
seguirá cayendo lana y cuando lo tengas
te vas a dar cuenta que no se trata de
eso no se trata de los lujos no se trata
de los carros no se trata en esta era
digital en la que vivimos de los
followers no se trata de los likes no se
trata de los shares no se trata en los
comentarios no se trata de eso
se trata de estar bien y compartir de
nada sirve tenerlo todo de verdad si no
tienes con quien compartirlo
no se puede tener todo en la vida
frase matón de nuestra sociedad
no se puede tener todo en la vida no si
se puede pero no al mismo tiempo si se
puede yo no puedo trabajar en y es bien
y vivir el mexicalli no se puede está
bien
puedo trabajar en la ciudad de mexico y
que me digital y sea mi lugar favorito
para ir de vacaciones eso si se puede y
entonces si puedo combinar mi trabajo
con mi familia si se puede si lo pueden
hacer
no se puede tener todo en la vida
super mediocre e
nunca me gustó esta frase le agregué
tres puntos se dice la mía
al menos al mismo tiempo está bien
no
no puedo salir del canal e ir a comer
con mi familia en mi casa en mexicalli
no puedo pueden ir a méxico podemos
comer todos juntos podemos regresar al
canal
y al final todo va a estar bien todo
de verdad si algo no está bien
síganle dando con todo
depende de ti que si al final tú dices
cuando se acaba tu misión tú te encargas
de hacer que valga la pena haber salido
de tu zona de confort ya le estás dando
dale con todo no nada más le des
quiero trabajar y ponte a trabajar duro
todo el mundo trabaja
yo quiero esto está perfecto dale
primer fracaso segundo fracaso tercer
fracaso tienes que seguir yendo hacia
adelante
tú decides cuándo es el final y de
verdad lo creo y de verdad está acá que
te mueve que es lo que siempre has
querido hacer y no has hecho qué es lo
que te quite el sueño en la noche qué es
lo que no te deja dormir
se acaba el día apagar la tele agarras
del celular y le empieza a mover
y vas de twitter a instagram a facebook
a whatsapp
a las fotos
y ahí te vas hasta que se te cae en la
cara dormido y entonces ya morir
y no te puedes dormir porque estás
pensando en eso que siempre escribió
hacer porque de eso se trata la vida
porque somos más de 7000 millones de
personas en el mundo tiene que haber una
razón por la que estamos aquí una una al
menos una de verdad
así me veía cuando me gradué de la
preparatoria
qué ridículo
david bisbal está de moda
me mucho a empezar a destacar en la
portería de mexico
es lo que había
busque fotos
de cuando era más chico todavía estaba
en la primaria está en la secundaria
quién mexicalli si me conocieron en esos
tiempos qué pena
perdón
pesaba 101 kilos y medio en segundo el
secundario que me puse dieta 101 kilos y
medio
van todos a william el gordo
no hay fotos las destruimos las encontré
en mi casa no hay fotos
pero lo más importante y de verdad lo
que tiene que quedar bien claro
sigue no pares empuje te estira la liga
llegaste a una meta que sigue otra
no se trata de cruzar la meta porque las
cruces
esto era todo es el proceso es el camino
es el día a día es exigirse es saber que
tú puedes ser lo que tú quieras ser lo
que sea
de mexicalli baja california para el
mundo para bien o para mal es lo que hay
tú decides
y vamos a juntarnos todos y vamos a
seguir poniendo musical en el mapa y
vamos a hacer más ruido arriba mexicalli
y puro cachanilla muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]